hi
in this video i'm going to talk about
ldl and why ldl is called
bad cholesterol what are the effects if
ldl level in the blood is high
we would see all these concepts in this
video
so
before knowing ldl we should
consider two other type of lipoprotein
in our body ldl stands for low density
lipoprotein so the protein part in this
part like light protein is pretty low
so let's see
and analyze what are other lipoproteins
from which ldl is actually derived
so
here is our liver
and liver secretes one type of particle
called
vldl
and vldl stands for very low density
lipoprotein
vldl have
apple b100 lipoprotein
it has apple e
and apoc2
and this vldl
is now circulating in the
blood all around the body
and let's say the vldl
reaches a adipose tissue
and in the adipose tissue
there
so here i present
the adipose tissue
so here in the adipose tissue ldl
vldl actually uh
encounters
lipoprotein libraries
now when
our vldl particle
containing
b100
apple e and apoc2
encounters this lpl
that means lipoprotein lipase
and c2 actually helps it to
dock to this uh lpl
and now the triglyceride inside the
vldl would be
converted
into
the triglyceride that is inside the vldl
triglyceride would be converted into
free fatty acid
and free fatty acid would be stored in
the adipose tissue
so
the particle we would get now it has a
lot of cholesterol
and it is called
intermediate density lipoprotein
idl it still have the apple b100 tag it
have apple e but don't have a c2 because
during the tracking
uh
into the adipose tissue that tag is lost
that lipoprotein is lost
now this l idl could get back into the
circulation so here i am representing
idl
it has
b100
it has e
so now idl would again
flow in
capillaries and it would go circulate
all around the body
ideal could be converted
into another particle
called
the ldl so ldl has apple b
100 and apple e
now what happens to this ldl is
ldl could be taken up by the liver
so 50 of the ldl is taken up the by the
liver because liver has
particular apoe receptor for this type
of
ldl particles
so 50 percent
is taken up
by liver
and what happened to the rest 50 percent
the rest 50 percent
this is ldl
the rest 50 percent actually circulates
around the body
and it actually supply cholesterol to
the sources where we need cholesterol
but when the ldl level is high due to
some reason
ldl would do bad stuffs to our body
say for instance this is our ldl so it's
in a
further place in the artery
and in artery
ldl
could ultimately deposits its
cholesterol content
and form
a plaque
or atrogenic block
so ldl
may
build
anthrogenic plaque
so this is the bad effect of
cholesterol and now we would see
how
this block actually formed
so now if we zoom into our area
of this particular artery
if we zoom
into this portion
we would find we would have a lot of
epithelial endothelial cells of the
arterial lining have a lot of them
we have a lot of endothelial cells
and here it would be the lumen
here would be the lumen
and beneath that we would get a sub
endothelial space
after the sub endothelial space
in the sub endothelial space
we have
smooth muscular layer
these are smooth muscle cells
so these are
smooth muscle cells
and now what happens
and here is the lumen so we can see
rbc's over here
and in case of
when a body has a lot of
ldl
here the ldl level in blood is very high
so there are a lot of circulatory ldl
now what happens this ldl could get
inside to the sub endothelial space
and by some mechanism
this ldl
would actually be converted
into its oxidized form
this form is known as
oxidized
ldl
in the meantime
we have lot of
monocytes
circulating around the
blood vessels and lumen so this oxidized
ldl
would actually
help this
endothelial cells to express adhesion
molecules
here you can see
due to these oxidized ldl
these endothelial cells
can produce
these adhesion molecules
now these monocytes would be actually
talked into these
adhesion molecules
and ultimately the monocytes
would get inside the tissue
and when it's inside the sub endothelial
space
it would be
a macrophage
it would be
a macrophage
a tissue macrophage
now macrophage has scavenger receptors
and these scavenger receptors can
actually uptake these
oxidized form of ldl
and now
it can really take the
oxidized form of ldl
when macrophage takes a lot of this
oxidized ldl macrophage
get converted into a specific type of
cell known as
foam cells
these are foam cells
and these foam cells are actually the
main culprit
for building up atherogenic block
now remember foam cells have a lot of
ldl particles inside a lot of
cholesterol inside and due to its high
cytotoxicity
these foam cells would actually
get ruptured
it would be destroyed
and releasing it content into the
sub endothelial space
in the sub endothelial space a lot of
deposition of these
ldl would take place
and ultimately a plug would be developed
in the mouth of the block
lot of rbcs
could be attracted
forming a thrombus
and this is the most extreme case
so this is atherogenic block actually
represented in green this is a plaque
this is a plaque and this is this is the
thomas
so
just reviewing again
that
we have
excess level of ldl circulating ldl so
ldl would get inside and ldl would be
converted into oxidized ldl if the high
am if the ross reactive oxygen species
is in high amount then ldl could get
converted into oxidized ldl this
oxidized ldl could be taken up by the
macrophage and where does the macrophage
came into the picture the macrophage
actually came into the picture
when circulating monocytes get inside
the cell due to a lot of adhesion
receptors and these tissue macrophage
would take these
oxidized ldl particle and
it would become foam cell and due to the
cytotoxicity of foam cell form cell
would rupture releasing its content into
the sub endothelial space and ultimately
the endothelial lining would be broken
down
a lot of thrombus could form
a pluck could build up
and
this is
the ultimate result is
atherosclerosis
which is a terrible disease and if this
atherosclerosis happens in the coronary
artery it could be fatal even
so that is why
ldl is called bad cholesterol
but the
ldl is also required for our body
because ldl is the main source of
cholesterol
ldl
could supply cholesterol to the tissues
whose who actually need cholesterol for
many purposes like steroid hormone
biosynthesis or any other purposes
so ldl is good but
too much excess of ldl would cause
damage to our body and ultimately would
lead to atherogenesis and
atherosclerosis that is why ldl is also
known as
bad cholesterol hope you understand the
video hope you enjoyed please like and
subscribe thank you